самого на
верховна просто вважається їсти через
кордон із правда політика bespeco
федерика могерині
складу від іммо список санкцій
сенцова савченко резолюцію з праху ним
стоїть і так і список європарламенту
славі та офіс саме he-man поки не
травня вона хто країн операційний нон грата
в'їзд євро пантері не приходьте та врятував
dc застудив прокурорів ставок їх то
викрасів савченко сенцова та кольченко
кофлера російський режим не абстрактний
я конкретніше у собаки нас правді у
хвалити рішення ми ви не чит кавказу
ти нацик людей і геть і по ви не розумієш
і що імунітету після товщі він з рук
була німа speak in the bold європейська
силічі відчинити за на лізу відео
запустити пости на грам суднових
процесі над олегом Сєнцевим та
олександром кольченко mta надіюс овчинку
у своїй роботі ви на весь рік за стрибати
список магнітку п'ятірки в тому
кучеряня love персональний санкцій на
по ночі тут від російських суддів у
чиновники та слова київ лікарських доза
webley юриста сергія магнітного зйомки
гріха списку магнітку показав
персональні санкції дівочих його ми і факт
з не там і буду провалю розширити цю
практику і просодію в них у судових
процесах кольченко сенцова та інших
senscience ребекка хармс вигляду арту дим
влаштована чомусь боту і симпатії на о
каденції мобільного телефону тризуб she
один адвокат України голова
парламентського комітету та закордонних
справ ельмар брок
поважаючи син сильний список потрібно
закладену крученого я будуть ви кімнати з
мінського будинку у насті за край move часті
не ланки невельського полум'яних домогтися
але начебто скажу для зростання найголовніший
ще по мінську до молодості виковувався
алли водночас москва по ви на батчата
ще ми не можемо і змиріться з тим хочу
іноземних громадян українців та кіно
порушив її жадібних законі
вивозити до Росії і суддя там за
кримінальними статтями ту раша
противні усі депутати європарламенту
поважають що nuvi санкції та допоможе
зобов'язаним українцям і зможе в полоні ти
на позиції русі та росіяни це так
росіян та кольору пружини на цю та громад
від них ну ти і йди ти тупа але і ми ж
то реакція буде дуже сильно збрід nor
акція ви можете спостерігати абсолютно ваш
почитаєш його рейтинг шляху дорослої
акули захід за право джо і деталі більше
і більше санкцію зростає рейтинг він ціна
протягом ось це вже періоду
залишкове рішення з чудо списку
свинцево з овчинку за європейську радію
і найму повернеш і зробити а їм же після
ви руку надій савченко